oggi sono qui per raccontarvi tre storie
tre storie di tre bambini nati in epoche
e luoghi molto diversi
donato oliver e ruben donato e un
bambino che nasce in una famiglia comune
in un comune villaggio intorno al 1200
era un periodo molto difficile c'erano
tantissime malattie mortali in
circolazione e la povertà si stendeva
tantissimi strati della popolazione
quando un bambino si ammalava purtroppo
le famiglie erano spesso costretti ad
abbandonarlo non perché non volessero
avere cura dei loro bambini perché non
avevano le risorse necessarie pratiche
per avere cura di loro e perché avevano
paura che contagiasse altri membri della
famiglia
oggi per noi tutto questo oltre che
essere molto triste
ci sembra assurdo perché abbiamo capito
che i bambini sono i soggetti che
all'interno della nostra della nostra
società devono essere assolutamente
tutelati e protetti
infatti vi leggo una frase della
convenzione dei diritti dell'infanzia
scritta dalle nazioni unite che dice che
il bambino deve poter crescere e
svilupparsi in modo sano
a tal fine devono essere assicurate le
cure mediche e le protezioni sociali
adeguate il secondo bambino di cui vi
voglio parlare
si chiama oliver e probabilmente un
bambino che conoscete tutti
sto parlando di oliver twist il
protagonista del racconto di charles
dickens bene oliver rappresenta uno dei
tanti bambini che durante il xix secolo
specialmente
in gran bretagna durante la rivoluzione
industriale e rappresentavano una
grandissima forza lavoro perché erano
molto apprezzati per la loro piccola
corporatura specialmente per le loro
piccole mani perché riuscivano a fare
lavori che gli adulti non potevano
compiere
nonostante questo la società della gran
bretagna di quel periodo capisce
relativamente in fretta che la
situazione di lavoro minorile non è
sostenibile
quindi che cosa fa nel 1883 tira fuori
una bella legge questa legge che cosa ci
dice
i minori sotto i 9 anni non possono
lavorare quindi comunque al di sopra di
questa età i bambini continuano a
lavorare nelle fabbriche
questa piccola evoluzione della società
e della gran bretagna del xix secolo ci
fa capire una cosa che è che i diritti
dei bambini la tutela dei bambini è
molto legata all'evoluzione della nostra
civiltà
io credo che sia fondamentale capire
questo che non è una cosa scontata la
tutela dei bambini è una cosa che noi
abbiamo guadagnato con il tempo pensate
per esempio che sino a poco tempo fa i
bambini non venivano educati dei propri
genitori spesso e volentieri le loro
cure e la loro educazione ricadeva su
altre persone
la svolta più recente è stata dopo la
prima guerra mondiale perché perché
tantissimi stati si sono trovati in una
situazione in cui
c'erano tantissime vedove tantissimi
orfani quindi che cosa hanno pensato
giustamente è arrivato il momento di
tutelare questi bambini queste bambine
per avere in modo per avere il modo in
futuro di continuare ad avere delle
generazioni che portino avanti il nostro
mondo
la stessa convenzione della quale vi
parlavo poco fa infatti ci dice che i
bambini sono tutti uguali devono essere
protetti devono essere amati non possono
essere discriminati per questioni di
religione di razza di sesso di
provenienza hanno diritto a un nome è
una nazionalità devono essere protetti
da qualsiasi tipo di discriminazione
riguarda il lavoro minorile
c'è un'altra frase sempre di questa
stessa convenzione di quale sto parlando
che ci dice il fanciullo non deve essere
inserito nell'attività produttiva
prima di aver raggiunto un'età minima
adatta in nessun caso deve essere
costretto o autorizzato ad assumere
un'occupazione o un impiego che nocciano
alla sua salute o che ostacolino il suo
sviluppo fisico mentale o morale ben il
terzo bambino di cui vi voglio parlare
si chiama ruben è nato il 3 di agosto
del 2015 quindi pochi mesi fa quattro
mesi e mezzo fa ruben per i primi mesi
della sua vita purtroppo non ha goduto
di alcuni dei suoi diritti non ha avuto
un documento d'identità ha rischiato di
rimanere senza assistenza sanitaria non
è stato possibile assegnargli un
pediatra ed è rimasto bloccato per ben
due mesi in territorio spagnolo
ruben è nato in spagna a barcellona da
una donna italiana daniela i figli delle
donne italiane ovunque nascano sono
italiani quindi rumeno un bambino
italiano ma nonostante questo per ben
due mesi come vi dicevo prima non ha
goduto degli stessi diritti di cui
godono tutti i bambini italiani diritti
che generalmente giustamente diamo per
scontati daniela è una donna italiana
che vive in spagna
l'arte è una delle sue passioni e questa
è una delle cose che io e lei abbiamo in
comune
ve la presento qui la vedi la vedete
travestita da sirena clown partenope
questa foto risale alla serata in cui e
daniela ci siamo conosciute io
organizzato un evento artistico al quale
lei ha partecipato con questa con questo
numero clown
la mattina successiva a questo evento
ho trovato un suo messaggio su facebook
e ho deciso di invitarlo a offrire per
prendere un caffè
quella stessa sera io e daniela siamo
uscite abbiamo chiacchierato sino a
tardi e abbiamo passato una bellissima
serata
pochi giorni dopo è partito per un
viaggio abbastanza lungo ma nonostante
questo abbiamo continuato a sentirci al
suo ritorno ci siamo rivisti e piano
piano ci siamo innamorati
io e daniela viviamo in spagna a
barcellona
entrambe da sette anni insieme abbiamo
deciso di volere un bambino li potete
immaginare che non è una scelta semplice
prima c'è stata la convivenza poi
abbiamo iniziato a parlare
dell'argomento e fiduciose nella nostra
unione abbiamo deciso di volere
allargare la famiglia
quindi ci siamo informati e abbiamo
fatto inseminazione artificiale che fra
l'altro è in spagna abbiamo fatto presso
una struttura pubblica
questo è il nostro test di gravidanza
che ha una storia un po particolari la
seconda stanghetta quella che indica che
sei incinta quella più chiara all'inizio
non è comparsa
quindi questo test noi l'abbiamo buttato
nella spazzatura nonostante questo io e
daniele eravamo convinte che lei fosse
rimasta incinta non riuscivamo a
crederci quindi dopo un'oretta più o
meno daniela a ricontrollato questo test
di gravidanza ed era comparsa la seconda
linea quindi ovviamente stato momento di
grande emozione abbiamo pianto di gioia
poi lei ha fatto delle analisi ed
effettivamente ci hanno confermato che
stavamo aspettando un bambino
sempre durante la gravidanza che è un
momento molto particolare e molto bello
per me è stato fondamentale iniziare a
costruire un legame con il nostro bimbo
quando era ancora dentro il pancione e
oltre a questo abbiamo deciso di
sposarci perché era la maniera più
sicura di garantire al nostro bambino ea
noi il massimo dei diritti pochi mesi
dopo il nostro matrimonio è arrivato il
patto anzi prima del parto c'è stato il
travaglio quello di daniele durato 22
ore
poi alla fine il 3 di agosto alle 21 e
08 sotto il segno del leone è nato il
nostro piccolo ruben è stato un momento
incredibile io non riuscivo a parlare
l'unica cosa che potevo fare era
piangere poi quando mi sono più o meno
ripresa mi sono avvicinata a loro e ho
detto delle parole a ruben non saprei
dirvi quali non mi ricordo minimamente
però lui mi ha guardato mi ha guardato
fisso negli occhi ed è stato incredibile
è un momento che non potrò mai
dimenticare dopo la nascita
abbiamo registrato un ruberà il comune
di barcellona come prevede la legge
spagnola gli sono stati assegnati due
cognomi quello di daniela la madre
biologica e il mio dopo la registrazione
è arrivata la trascrizione in italia
obbligatoria perché perché ruben come vi
dicevo prima è figlio di una donna
italiana
non importa che sia nato in spagna lui
comunque italiano quindi l'italia è
l'unico paese che poteva dargli la
trascrizione che poi avrebbe dato il
documento d'identità per ruben tra le
altre cose
questa trascrizione non è stata
possibile poi forse vi chiederete il
perché per via del secondo cognome il
mio
dopo questo ostacolo iniziata la nostra
battaglia per ben due mesi abbiamo
lottato e abbiamo insistito e finalmente
l'atto di nascita di ruben è stato
trascritto in italia rispettando quello
spagnolo quindi riconoscendo come madri
legali di ruben sia daniela che me dopo
20 giorni però è arrivata una doccia
fredda
questo atto di nascita la trascrizione
di questo rinascita è stata contestata e
parzialmente annullata
adesso io qui non ho nessun diritto come
madre di ruben e ruben per la seconda
volta viene privato di alcuni dei suoi
diritti
pensate che se abitassimo qua io non
potrei accompagnarlo a scuola
e se avesse qualche problema di salute i
medici non potrebbero parlarne con me
che sono sua madre
ad ogni modo oggi non sono qui per
parlare delle problematiche tecniche
pratiche giuridiche che stiamo
affrontando e che stiamo cercando di
risolvere
sono qui per parlare di diritti si
diritti diritti per i bambini l'infanzia
deve essere dovrebbe essere il momento
più felice della vita di tutti noi
e il momento in cui si formano le donne
e gli uomini che costruiranno la società
del futuro
e per questo che dobbiamo tutelare al
massimo tutti i nostri bambini
bambini come donato come oliver come
ruben che ancora oggi devono affrontare
tantissime difficoltà bambini e bambine
che nascono ogni giorno in ogni parte
del mondo
la convenzione dei diritti dell'infanzia
scritta nel 1959 ci ricorda ancora una
volta una cosa fondamentale che diritti
devono essere riconosciuti a tutti i
fanciulli senza alcuna eccezione
senza distinzione e discriminazione
fondata sulla razza il colore il sesso
la lingua la religione opinioni
politiche o di altro genere le origine
nazionale o sociale le condizioni
economiche la nascita ogni altra
condizione sia che si riferisca al
fanciullo stesso o alla sua famiglia
io voglio dire una cosa alla quale credo
veramente
io credo che è compito di tutti noi
garantire a tutti i bambini veramente
gli stessi diritti ai bambini italiani
quelli stranieri
i bambini ricchi i bambini poveri orfani
quelli che nascono con un padre con una
madre e quelli che nascono dall'amore di
una famiglia omogenitoriale grazie